hello and welcome to feed bakula the
show that by all rights should have
really been sued for libel by now but
somehow we're still standing still can't
blame a guy for trying
that should do it coming up this week
who exactly is this place sonic boom
that's the slightly confusing name of
the new Sonic game from Sega that
definitely isn't going to cause them any
problems with search engine optimization
the game was announced late this week
along with this trailer designed to
convince you the game is good and that
dubstep is somehow still culturally
relevant it also shows off the newly
redesigned cast of characters some of
whom look very very different indeed our
community reaction was as is so often
the way when it comes to big change
pretty colorful did I say colorful i
meant hateful those redesigns it hideous
well their proportions changed a lot o
underscore Oh looks like Kunkel skip leg
day knuckles a once powerful and
respected warrior than equal to Sonic
and an exciting new character to play as
with climb glide and run through walls
has now been roided up and made into a
total douche bag that only wants to get
on the sun beds and jab up aight i call
it quits I completely get up on this
series saya can keep donkey kong's and
Knuckles his love child so sonic is a
hipster the kind of loser who wears a
scarf when it's hot outside naw cars you
had it too small for your body and sorry
your legs are weird Amy be useful and
tail stop sounding like your nose is
stuffed up you know they're fictional
characters right they can't actually you
know hear you sonic boom worst game and
be worst game on will you and be layoffs
to Sega this year as well being a
knuckles fan I hope they don't keep this
design in future iterations knuckles has
always been awesome there's a freakishly
strong normal-sized guy making him the
big guy isn't appealing to me I can deal
with it for one game but still really
really hope it doesn't stick also his
knuckles on is cool anymore that's just
twisted knuckles his knuckles are the
same that's some pretty matter sorrow
right there so yeah it seems the new
artistic direction for Sonic and pals
isn't exactly popular with our common
but then they do ask a good question
what the hell has happened to knuckles I
mean okay the scarves and bandages are a
bit weird but I can cope with that but
knuckles really heat he just doesn't
look very well i sat down with renowned
naturalist albert wharfedale to find out
just what's going on well obviously this
is a very rare physical anomaly one we
rarely see in monitoring species such as
the echidna there are many things that
may have brought it on perhaps a change
in diet unusual environmental stress or
a developer clutching desperately at
straws thanks al so the results may be
inconclusive but that's okay because not
everyone hates the look of sonic boom
granted there weren't exactly many of
them but they do exist watch I like it
knuckles always blue sonic away on the
cool factor back of the Genesis days at
least knows entirely different compared
for Sonic you should have been like this
in the Genesis DS if the Genesis could
have handled it aside from the excessive
amount of tape I don't mind the
redesigns of course i know everyone will
hate them because you know sonic fanbase
it looks good it could be like a true
sonic adventure free but more like sa1
they overdid it of the bandages and
Knuckles new look will take some getting
used to but I like it so far should
people really complain about Sega
ruining their childhood when they were
the ones who created it at least Sega
was trying to make it fresh I've had
worse argument than that guys the
co-founder of developing team is Bob
refe the guy who helped made the
original crash bandicoot games of
naughty dog all jak and daxter games and
the first uncharted game so if there is
any hope of a good sonic game this is it
this seems to me like a reboot like what
sonic 06 was supposed to be because
there's no other explanation for
knuckles is redesign if it's still
within the current continuity if this is
a reboot then I see no problem with
knuckles is redesign considering
knuckles can punch down
at least his new bulk would explain how
he could do that trender man has mixed
views on that scarf thanks trenda man so
where does this leave us well the people
in favor of sonic boom were definitely
in the minority trapped in a sea of
pissed off people but at least they do
exist maybe the game will be the shot in
the arm sonic desperately needs maybe
not but if nothing else sonic boom is
certainly a bold gamble but what I'm
left wondering is this is it the right
time for Sega to be taking such wild
swings sonic has had a bit of a time
over the last few games to put it
lightly and faith in the franchise isn't
exactly at an all-time high the trailer
for sonic boom feels like they're trying
really hard to do too many things at
once and that's a bit worrying for Sega
sake I hope it isn't a complete dog's
dinner but then when your main gimmicks
for revitalization of scarves bandages
and steroids well that's not hugely
encouraging I should know that's
Cameron's winter wardrobe